今天我们要来聊一个很狂的话题
你知道吗
有一位交易员
他在过去五年
光是交易的总金额
就超过了一兆台币
没错
你没听错
是一兆
一兆元
我们是停一下
感受一下这个数字
一后面有12个零
而且这还不是他的身家
是在过去短短五年内
他在市场上你知道吗
真枪实弹买进卖出的总成交金额
真的很惊人
重点是
这么惊人的数字
居然是来自同一个人
市场上
大家都叫它巨人节
所以问题来了
到底是什么样的思考方式
才能让一个人
在压力这么大的市场里
处理这么庞大的交易
好
这就是我们今天
要带大家深入了解的
好
今天我们会分成五个部分
来猜解它的心法
首先所谓的一兆元公式
到底是什么
再来
它认为交易的本质
其实不是看线图
第三我们会讲到十分钟的优势有多值钱
第四这部分很关键
怎么去重设你的交易大脑
最后聊聊为什么一个行情
会有三种完全不同的故事
好我们就从第一个开始吧
好第一个部分
一照员公事
我想很多人包括我自己
都会觉得
哇这么厉害的交易员
一定有什么超级神秘的独门秘技吧
但有趣的是巨人节一开始就告诉我们
不是你想的那样哦
他给出的核心公式
说出来你可能会吓一跳
真的非常简单
他说交易策略就等于经验加上逻辑
就这样
这听起来好像没什么大不了的
但关键就在于
这不是什么你学不会的武功秘籍
而是一种只要你愿意
就可以复制的思考方式
那他所谓的经验到底是什么
其实讲白了
就是对市场现象非常细微的观察
你想想看哦
你有没有注意到好像每年过年前市场都会有一波卖压或者美股修市的时候台股好像都会有特别的走势这些就是了巨人节认为
真正的策略就藏在这些
你每年都会看到
不断重复发生的现象里面
所以你需要的
根本不是什么秘籍
而是你自己的观察力
还有一点点的想象力
好 接下来第二点
巨人节提出一个
我觉得对很多人来说
可能有点颠覆性的建议
他说拜托
放下你的对那些K棒
技术线图的过度执着
为什么
因为那些都只是结果而已
我们真正该做的是
回到经济学
最最根本的原则
他用了一个超级生动的比喻
叫做台风与高利财
你想一般人是怎么样
是等到电视新闻开始爆
台风警报了
才冲去市场抢高利财
但真正的高少
他们是每天都在看气象图
当他看到太平洋上有个台风点正在行程
他脑中就已经推论出
高丽菜的攻击马上就要减少了
然后在菜价真的涨起来之前
他就已经先进场了
你看这就是交易的精髓
所以你看这就是最大的差别
我们大部分业余玩家
是专注在解读K棒
也就是那个已经发生的结果
但是职业的交易员
他们是专注在分析
供需关系
也就是驱动价格变动的
那个最根本的原因
好
所以如果我们说
供需是交易的核心逻辑
那资讯就是让这个逻辑
跑起来的燃料
而且你知道吗
顶尖的交易员
他们愿意花大钱去追求的
可能只是
哪怕只有10分钟的资讯有始
你看这个数字
这就是巨人节
每年付给一家
叫做Trendforce的
研究机构的费用
将近15万台币
你可能会想
哇这资讯也太贵了吧
但对他来说
他花的不是钱
他是在买一个最关键的东西
就是时间
这就是职业和业域最大的差别你看哦假设在早上10点50这些专业人士拿到了关于记忆体晶片的独家报价数据等到11点这个消息变成公开新闻
我们一般人才看到的时候
市场早就已经天翻地覆了
就是这短短的10分钟
就成为专业交易员的一道
你几乎无法跨越的护城河
好 接下来我们要谈的这一部分
我得先说
这可能是整个新法里面
最违反我们一般人直觉
但也是最最关键的一部分
就是关于心理素质的刻意修炼
你看看这句话
真的非常震撼
他说要把赔三百块的痛感
修院到跟赚三十万的爽感一样强烈
这完全跟我们一般人相反
对吧
我们通常是赔个小钱
哎呀没感觉
但赚到大钱就开心到不行
去人解决要求自己
对任何一点点的亏损
都要感觉到剧痛
但反过来对巨大的获利
却要保持一颗平常心
那为什么要这样做
其实这就非常巧妙的解释了
为什么我们大部分的人
都做不到所谓的赚多赔少
因为我们的人性就是
小赔算了不在乎
然后一赚钱就急着想跑
只有透过这种
有点极端的痛感训练
你才能把自己的身体训练成
可以自然地做出快速停损
然后让获利继续跑的
这种反射动作
这里有一个很实用的自我检测表
你可以问问自己
如果你做完一笔交易
心里的感觉是
嗯 我真厉害
这代表什么
代表你刚刚执行了你的纪律
但如果你心里想的是
哎 早知道就
或是拜托希望他会弹回来
那就要小心了
这表示你的决策
很可能已经被情绪给绑架了。
好,来到我们最后一个部分,
我们来聊一个很有趣的现象,
为什么明明是同一段市场行情,
同一张K线图,
不同的人看到的,却是完全不同的世界?关键就在于你的立场,或者说说你手上的部位我们来假设一个很常见的状况
有一档股票
它前面涨了一大段非常强势
然后呢
现在开始回档修正了
好我们就来看看
三种不同立场的人
会怎么解读这张一模一样的图
第一种人就是那个
刚刚才卖掉股票的人
他看到下跌
心里会想什么
我好险啊
我跑得真快
看吧
趋势结束了
他那种松了一口气的庆幸感
很可能会让他完全忽略掉
这其实可能只是一个健康的整理
后面还有更大的一段行情
再来第二种人
那个空手一直想买
但错过行情的人
他看到下跌会觉得
太好了终于等到拉回了
这就是我上车的机会啊
但是他那种害怕再次错过的焦虑感
也常常会让他
刚好就买在一个更大跌式的起点
最后第三种人
这也是最危险的一种
就是那个买在最高点
现在被套牢的人
他看到股价跌下来会怎么想
他会告诉自己
现在价格变便宜了
我应该加码买进
把成本摊平
你看是他的希望
正在驱使他去扩大一个错误的决策
然后亏损就越滚越大
直到完全无法收拾
所以说交易真的是一条非常非常辛苦的路
巨人节最后也分享他说
能够支撑他走过这一造源交易规模的
其实不是什么过人的毅力或努力
而是一种最单纯的
对交易这件事本身的喜爱
那么在今天我们整个分析结束之前
也留一个问题给大家回去想一想
当你看到同一张线图
同一个市场波动的时候
你最常告诉自己的
是那三种故事里的哪一种呢
是卖方的庆幸
场外买方的焦虑
还是那个被套牢的人的希望
嗯
或许
你的答案就决定了
你和顶尖交易员之间的聚会